Quand Hitler triomphe à l'été 1940,
acclamé par les Allemands,
son peuple le prend
pour un génie infaillible,
doté d'une intelligence
hors du commun.
Seulement,
c'est une image
créée de toute pièce.
- Le mythe d'Hitler
qui est vendu aux Allemands,
c'est le Führer qui sait tout,
qui travaille jour et nuit,
dont la lumière du bureau
ne s'éteint jamais,
c'est l'exact contraire
de la réalité.
Hitler est un dilettante,
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a jamais travaillé.
- C'est quelqu'un qui ne supporte pas
l'effort intellectuel à long terme
et de longue haleine,
et qui est incapable de lire
un dossier de plus de 20 pages.
Hitler ne travaille pas.
En fait, Hitler aime
se retirer dans son refuge
comme un artiste
qui plane au-dessus de la réalité.
Une poignée de collaborateurs
travaille à sa place,
ils s'appellent
Joseph Goebbels,
Heinrich Himmler
ou Albert Speer.
Hitler a mis plus de 15 ans
à les recruter.
- On dirait aujourd'hui que c'est un bon
gestionnaire des ressources humaines,
il s'est très bien entouré
en choisissant des compagnons
qui lui apportaient à chaque fois
quelque chose de supplémentaire.
Qui sont ces hommes
dans l'ombre d'Hitler ?
Quel est le rôle de chacun ?
Autour du Führer,
il existe un vaste réseau
de collaborateurs.
Tout d'abord,
il y a la garde rapprochée,
les seuls qui ont
un accès direct à lui.
Parmi ses fidèles,
s'est constitué un trio essentiel
dont le premier personnage
est Hermann Goering.
C'est un ogre
qui ne pense qu'à s'enrichir.
Boulimique,
opportuniste, drogué,
il aime le luxe
et les extravagances.
Le deuxième,
Joseph Goebbels
est un écrivain raté.
Son handicap à la jambe
le complexe,
il se venge
par une haine radicale.
Il ne vit qu'à travers
son idole, Hitler.
Le troisième,
Heinrich Himmler,
est un petit bourgeois,
froid,
borné, méticuleux.
Un homme lisse
qui deviendra l'assassin du siècle
en organisant
ce que les Nazis appellent
La Solution Finale.
Le deuxième cercle est composé
d'hommes plus jeunes
et plus ambitieux
qui rejoignent Hitler dans les années 30
quand il accède au pouvoir
et distribue les Ministères.
Parmi eux,
Albert Speer va se hisser au sommet.
Sous les traits
d'un architecte distingué,
il est en fait
un grand manipulateur
qui partage
les rêves mégalomanes d'Hitler,
prêt à tout
pour devenir son préféré.
Enfin,
en bas de l'échelle,
il y a les exécutants sur le terrain,
les fonctionnaires
du Troisième Reich
qui commettent les crimes
et les atrocités,
comme Rudolf Hoess,
le commandant
du camp d'Auschwitz-Birkenau,
totalement froid et méprisant.
Ce père de famille installé
avec sa femme et ses cinq enfants
dans une maison en bordure du camp,
organisera l'extermination
de 1,1 million de personnes.
À ses côtés,
le docteur Joseph Mengele.
Il est en charge
d'expériences médicales,
il incarne
la cruauté des Nazis.
Sans pitié pour ses victimes,
ce médecin SS procède
aux pires mutilations dans les camps,
y compris sur des enfants.
Sans eux,
les pires crimes
n'auraient pas été possibles.
Pour plaire à Hitler,
ils sont en compétition.
Autour d'Hitler,
ils se détestent tous.
C'est un mode de fonctionnement
de cette petite communauté,
encouragé par Hitler,
qui suscite les rivalités,
la concurrence et l'émulation.
Hitler, encore inconnu,
va recruter ses complices
au début des années 20
dans une Allemagne en plein trouble.
Les vaincus
de la Première Guerre mondiale
n'ont plus qu'une armée
réduite à 100 000 hommes.
Alors partout,
d'anciens soldats constituent
encore des groupes de mercenaires.
Le pays a peur de basculer
dans la guerre civile.
Dans ce cortège,
un groupuscule du Sud de l'Allemagne
a choisi comme symbole,
la croix gammée.
Ils s'appellent,
le Parti national-socialiste
des travailleurs allemands,
N.S.D.A.P.
Né à Munich,
ce petit parti attire
les ouvriers et les chômeurs.
Au premier rang des spectateurs,
Hitler, 30 ans,
petit employé de l'Armée,
mais pas encore son chef,
il n'est que son 55ème adhérent.
Cet ancien combattant de 14-18
a connu les combats sur le front
au grade de simple caporal.
Depuis la défaite,
il ne pense plus qu'à venger l'Allemagne.
Hitler s'impose rapidement
comme le leader du petit parti
en prenant la parole
dans les brasseries de Munich.
Il dénonce les humiliations
infligées à son pays,
mais ses moyens
sont encore très limités.
Aménagé
dans cette arrière-salle de brasserie,
voici son premier bureau.
Il écrit ses discours
sur ce modeste coin de table.
Pour avoir plus d'écho,
il manque à Hitler
des représentants plus prestigieux.
À l'automne 1922,
quand une personnalité vient l'écouter,
il sent qu'il a trouvé
un candidat idéal.
- Hitler était vraiment plein de joie
parce que là,
il disait qu'ils avaient
quelqu'un de fortuné,
un héros de guerre,
que c'était la propagande
qu'il leur fallait,
que c'était quelqu'un
qu'il fallait absolument avoir
en tant que membre de leur parti.
La nouvelle recrue
a un certain panache.
Hermann Goering, 27 ans,
a été pilote de chasse
pendant la Grande Guerre.
En combat dans le ciel,
il a abattu 21 avions.
Hermann Goering a même
été décoré pour sa bravoure
de la Croix pour le mérite,
la plus haute distinction de l'Armée.
- C'était pratiquement
le seul héros
que la propagande allemande
a mis en avant.
On a fait des cartes postales
et tout le monde en Allemagne
avait plus ou moins connaissance
des exploits de tel ou tel officier,
et c'est pour cela que Goering
était quelqu'un de très connu,
avec des décorations,
c'est vraiment un personnage
à ce moment-là.
Après-guerre, comme l'aviation
militaire allemande est dissoute,
il est sans emploi.
Mais aux yeux d'Hitler,
Goering présente un autre intérêt,
il a des relations haut placées.
- Goering lui a apporté son prestige
et son réseau social considérable.
L'As de l'aviation a épousé
une femme fortunée,
Carin von Fock est issue
de la noblesse suédoise.
Ils se sont rencontrés
dans le château familial,
près de Stockholm.
Le couple fréquente l'aristocratie,
et justement,
Hitler a besoin de donateurs
pour financer son petit mouvement.
Dès son entrée dans le parti,
Goering est immédiatement propulsé
à la tête de la milice armée, appelée SA.
Moins d'un an plus tard, à Munich,
le parti nazi veut prendre le pouvoir
par un coup d'État.
Pendant ce putsch
de novembre 1923,
une fusillade éclate
entre les Nazis et la police.
On dénombre 16 morts.
Pour les Nazis,
c'est un échec total.
Hitler est enfermé huit mois
dans la prison forteresse de Landsberg,
son parti est dissous.
En cellule,
il écrit Mein Kampf,
en français,
Mon Combat.
Gravement blessé par balle,
Goering, lui, est en cavale.
Il est interdit de territoire
sur le sol allemand.
Il doit être opéré
et il est traité à la morphine
pour atténuer sa douleur.
Il devient dépendant à la drogue.
Goering se réfugie à Stockholm
dans le pays de sa femme.
Sans profession et sans avenir,
il a des accès de violence.
- Ça lui donne une crise mentale
et à partir du moment
où il devient aussi
un peu difficile à gérer,
sa femme préfère le mettre
dans un asile, pour le traiter.
Goering fait plusieurs séjours
dans cet hôpital psychiatrique
des environs de Stockholm.
Selon son dossier médical
confidentiel,
il a été admis
pour une intoxication à la morphine.
Goering est dépeint
comme suicidaire, égocentrique.
Il explique
ses troubles psychiques
parce qu'il se voit
comme politiquement mort.
L'année suivante,
il renaît de ses cendres.
Grâce à l'élection présidentielle
de 1925,
une amnistie vient d'être proclamée.
Il est autorisé
à rentrer en Allemagne.
Sans son Führer,
Goering n'est rien,
il espère reprendre
sa place de chef dans le parti,
mais le courant
ne passe plus avec Hitler.
- Hitler, au début,
n'était pas tellement chaud
à revoir son ex-chef des SA
parce que maintenant,
il dispose d'un autre chef des SA.
Goering rappelle à Hitler
les services qu'il lui a rendu.
- Il a dit qu'il avait tout perdu,
qu'il était toujours
son plus fidèle collaborateur,
et dans ce cas-là,
c'était maintenant à lui
de montrer sa reconnaissance.
Hitler a besoin d'hommes dévoués,
et il lui trouve une nouvelle place.
Goering ne va plus
se battre dans les rues,
mais il doit conquérir
les salons mondains.
Il va lutter
pour retrouver son rang.
Il n'y parvient qu'en 1928,
quand il entre au Reichstag,
le Parlement allemand,
élu parmi les 12 premiers députés nazis.
En 1932,
il devient même
Président de cette assemblée.
Le deuxième complice
qu'Hitler recrute,
voit sa carrière dans le nazisme
s'envoler à l'âge de 29 ans.
Hitler commence par confier
à Joseph Goebbels
une mission très délicate.
Il l'envoie à Berlin,
la capitale de l'Allemagne.
Avec ses quatre millions d'habitants,
c'est à l'époque,
la plus grande métropole d'Europe.
Elle se compose d'immenses faubourgs
où s'entassent les ouvriers.
On la surnomme Berlin la Rouge,
parce que les communistes
en ont fait leur bastion.
Hitler lance un immense défi
à ce petit homme boiteux,
faire des Nazis
la première force politique de Berlin,
et le Führer sait qu'il peut
tout demander à Goebbels.
- C'est un homme en quête éperdue
et affamé de reconnaissance.
Il la trouve en Hitler,
qu'il considère comme étant
un homme charismatique,
intelligent, supérieur
et envers lequel
il développe une relation
quasiment amoureuse.
Il se trouve dans une dépendance
affective réelle à l'égard d'Hitler,
donc il quête la reconnaissance,
les gestes amicaux,
les mots aimables.
Goebbels doit tout à Hitler,
car jusqu'à leur rencontre,
sa vie n'a été
qu'une succession d'échecs.
Atteint d'une maladie
dans la petite enfance,
Goebbels est handicapé
à la jambe,
il en a honte.
Pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale,
il a rêvé de devenir soldat.
Pour expliquer son infirmité,
il préfère mentir.
Il masque son handicap
en masquant l'origine,
en disant qu'il avait été blessé
pendant la Grande Guerre,
et qu'il était un héros,
or, il n'a pas combattu
pendant la Grande Guerre
parce qu'il n'a pas été enrôlé.
Docteur en littérature
de l'université,
écrivain sans succès,
il n'a pas trouvé d'emploi
à la hauteur de ses ambitions.
Goebbels a travaillé neuf mois
comme petit employé de banque
avant de démissionner.
Seul Hitler donne du sens à sa vie.
- Il n'est plus
le petit employé de banque,
il n'est plus le petit écrivaillon
éconduit par les grands éditeurs,
il est maintenant
le chef du parti nazi
pour une zone importante
qui est celle de la capitale du Reich.
À son arrivée à Berlin,
le nouveau chef ne trouve
qu'une centaine de membres actifs
et de petits bureaux,
tout est à construire.
Goebbels commence
par créer un journal,
l'Angriff,
l'Attaque en français.
Pour faire parler des Nazis,
il choisit une stratégie radicale,
attiser la haine.
Moins d'une semaine
après son arrivée,
Goebbels envoie ses gros bras
défier les communistes dans leur quartier.
De violentes bagarres éclatent,
des arrestations
massives ont lieu.
La police interdit le parti nazi
dans la capitale du Reich,
mais peu importe pour Goebbels,
le mouvement se nourrit du scandale.
Dans ce climat violent,
la propagande nazie se trouve un martyr.
En 1930, un jeune militant,
Horst Wessel,
a été poignardé à mort par un communiste.
En présence
d'Hitler et de Goering,
ces funérailles
en grande pompe
donnent l'occasion d'une démonstration
de force impressionnante pour les Nazis,
et Goebbels ne cesse
de jeter de l'huile sur le feu.
"Méritait-il vraiment cette mort ?
Qu'il avait du courage
de marcher dans la tempête,
ce jeune travailleur allemand,
droit,
et fier."
Pour le récompenser,
Hitler offre une promotion à Goebbels,
il le nomme
chef de la propagande du parti.
Le troisième homme
de la garde rapprochée d'Hitler
n'a pas le profil habituel
des ouvriers et des chômeurs
qui rejoignent le nazisme.
Heinrich Himmler
est un jeune bourgeois,
obsédé par la supériorité
de la race germanique.
Au siège du parti à Munich,
dans ce film de propagande
datant de 1929,
Himmler est ce jeune homme
à lunettes.
Il apparaît encore
comme un petit secrétaire subalterne
aux ordres de son chef.
Les autres ne perçoivent pas
ses ambitions.
Himmler est fils de bonne famille.
Catholique,
parfaitement intégré dans la société,
il est le fils
d'un professeur de latin grec,
devenu proviseur
d'un des meilleurs lycées de la ville.
Il ne manque de rien,
mais très jeune,
il adhère au groupe raciste
les plus radicaux.
Katrin Himmler
est la petite-fille d'Ernst,
le plus jeune frère
d'Heinrich Himmler.
Cette politologue étudie
l'histoire de sa famille.
Les trois frères Himmler
sont devenus des Nazis virulents.
- Leur idéologie se rapprochait
d'un sentiment de supériorité,
le sentiment que le peuple allemand
était au-dessus des autres.
Ce discours raciste prône aussi
un retour à la terre.
Himmler devient
ingénieur agronome.
Avec sa femme Marga,
ils achètent une petite ferme
où ils veulent vivre en autarcie
pour se protéger du monde extérieur
qu'ils considèrent pourri.
Aux côtés d'Hitler,
Himmler se montre soumis,
mais il a aussi
une vraie influence sur lui.
- En réalité,
on sait depuis qu'il a défendu
ses propres convictions.
Il obtenait
souvent l'accord d'Hitler
pour des idées
qu'il avait eues lui-même.
Himmler, le jeune bourgeois,
croit aux idées nazies,
mais il n'aime pas se mêler
aux militants de base
qui constituent
le cœur du parti.
- Aux yeux d'Himmler,
ces gens sont, on pourrait dire,
des imbéciles décérébrés,
c'est l'équivalent d'un club de supporters
comme la Lazio
ou le PSG dans ses bonnes heures.
En réaction,
Himmler crée donc
un club chic au sein du parti.
Ces hommes en noir disciplinés
formeront une élite sous son autorité.
Le sigle de cette unité en allemand
se compose de deux lettres,
les SS.
Tous doivent être impérativement
de pure origine germanique,
ils seront les plus fanatiques
parmi les fanatiques.
Quand ce soir de 1933,
Adolf Hitler est nommé
chancelier d'Allemagne,
une nouvelle fois,
il ne veut pas travailler
comme son rôle l'exigerait.
- Il n'aime pas du tout
d'être obligé
de travailler tous les jours,
de 9 h à 17 h,
pour lui, c'est impensable.
Lorsqu'il a commencé,
entre guillemets,
sa carrière de chancelier,
à partir de quelques jours,
il a tout de suite insisté
que ce n'est pas à lui de travailler.
Une fois au pouvoir,
le partage des rôles
entre ses complices
va faire des gagnants
et des perdants.
Goebbels ne devient pas
tout de suite ministre,
quant à Goering, il triomphe.
Hitler le fait entrer dans
son premier gouvernement dès 1933,
et personne ne va accumuler
autant de titres que lui.
En 12 années de pouvoir,
il suffit de voir
la variété de ses uniformes.
Président de Prusse,
Grand veneur du Reich,
ministre de l'Air,
maréchal d'Empire.
Une débauche de décoration
qui déclenche
la jalousie de son grand rival,
Joseph Goebbels.
- Goebbels, au début, est assez sceptique
sur le rôle de Goering.
Il le décrit très bien comme étant
l'insupportable baudruche boursouflée,
bouffie de fatuité et de vanité,
un jouisseur vulgaire.
Un beauf en fait,
un nouveau riche qui veut du clinquant,
qui se pavane
dans des uniformes ridicules,
chamarré de médailles
et de fourragères.
C'est un pantin à ses yeux.
Seulement,
Goering est aussi un homme à poigne.
Il installe la dictature dès 1933.
Quand le Reichstag prend feu
dans des conditions mystérieuses,
Goering,
le Président de l'assemblée,
attribue l'incendie aux communistes
et se fait menaçant.
"Je vais balayer au balai de fer
tous ceux qui ont obtenu
des postes et des privilèges,
exclusivement grâce à leur
affiliation politique, rouge ou noire,
je vais les faire tomber."
Une vague de répression
s'abat sur l'Allemagne.
Plus de 3 000 opposants au nazisme
sont arrêtés sans jugement.
Goering crée
une nouvelle police politique,
la Gestapo.
Dès 1933,
le premier camp de concentration
ouvre à Dachau,
les opposants sont soumis
aux travaux forcés,
Goering gagne des points
dans l'estime d'Hitler.
- Goering a, à chaque fois,
la une
lorsqu'Hitler cherche quelqu'un
pour confier un travail difficile
à un de ses collaborateurs.
Joseph Goebbels finit lui aussi
par recevoir un poste taillé sur mesure,
un grand ministère
pour la propagande.
L'écrivain frustré a maintenant le pouvoir
de choisir les livres autorisés
et d'interdire les autres.
Les livres des écrivains juifs
ou des auteurs jugés dégénérés
sont brûlés
dans de grandes cérémonies publiques,
comme ce soir de mai 1933,
près de l'Université de Berlin.
"Vous faites bien de confier
les démons du passé
aux flammes.
L'homme allemand du futur
ne sera pas seulement
un homme de livres,
mais également
un homme de caractère,
et à cela,
nous voulons vous former."
Il est aussi
un antisémite fanatique.
Quand les Nazis
arrivent au pouvoir,
les Juifs ne représentent en Allemagne
que 0,8 pourcent de la population,
mais Goebbels imagine
une façon de les persécuter.
Des camions circulent dans les rues
pour propager un message.
"Soyons Allemands
et ne soyons plus Juifs !
Mes chers compatriotes,
ce matin à 10 h,
nous avons commencé
le boycott des commerçants juifs."
Les magasins tenus par des Juifs
sont pointés du doigt,
et les Nazis dissuadent
fermement les clients d'entrer.
Goebbels veut imposer
ses messages sur les ondes,
et pour que la propagande
entre dans tous les foyers,
il a même fait fabriquer exprès
un poste de radio bon marché.
Ce climat qu'il crée en Allemagne
est particulièrement oppressant
dans la famille
de la jeune Margit,
cinq ans, qui vit à Berlin.
Son père est juif, libraire
et vend des livres interdits.
- Je ne comprenais pas tout,
mais je sentais l'atmosphère.
On avait reçu de Goebbels
ces postes de radio du peuple
et j'entendais toujours
"Les Juifs sont notre malheur."
C'était la voix d'Hitler
et celle de Goebbels,
et moi, je ne savais absolument
pas ce qu'était un juif.
Joseph Goebbels surveille tout,
le théâtre, le cinéma
et il fait visionner les actualités
par un comité de censure tout-puissant.
Goebbels orchestre aussi
une mise en scène monumentale du régime,
en coulisse,
il règle les moindres détails.
Tout au long des années 30,
au cours d'immenses rassemblements
filmés comme
une superproduction hollywoodienne,
Hitler est présenté au peuple
comme le Messie.
La carrière de Joseph Goebbels
est à son apogée,
mais son caractère tourmenté
va reprendre le dessus.
- Goebbels est tout à fait à son aise
dans les situations de crise,
dans les situations de détresse,
de catastrophe.
Là, il n'est pas à son aise,
il a besoin de bruit et de fureur.
La tempête pour Goebbels
va venir de sa vie privée.
Il a épousé Magda en 1931
avec comme témoin de mariage,
Adolf Hitler.
Leurs enfants sont utilisés
au fil du temps par la propagande,
les Goebbels forment
la famille modèle du régime.
"Cher papa,
nous vois-tu marcher vers toi ?
Tu as déjà deviné
que nous sommes là pour te féliciter,
parce que
tu fêtes ton anniversaire.
Helmut !"
Les prénoms des six enfants
commencent tous par la lettre H
en hommage à Hitler.
Magda Goebbels,
décorée par le régime,
incarne la mère
de famille nazie idéale,
et chaque année,
une petite séquence est mise en scène
pour célébrer l'anniversaire du père.
"Dis : "Cher papa".
Vite, dis : "Cher papa".
Plus fort !
Nous te félicitons...
vraiment...
pour ton anniversaire...
parce que tu es au travail et tu ne
sais pas ce que nous faisons ici."
Joseph Goebbels cultive cette image
de bon père de famille,
comme ce soir de Noël 1936
où il se fait filmer
en train de distribuer des cadeaux
aux petits Allemands les plus modestes.
"Merci pour le petit mot.
Tu veux ça ?"
Seulement, la réalité n'a rien à voir
avec cette image parfaite.
- Goebbels est connu
pour multiplier les aventures,
il a besoin de divertissements,
d'actions et d'événements.
Comme il aime
et connaît très bien le cinéma,
comme il a une grande culture artistique,
il participe.
Une des manières de participer à la vie
du cinéma était de faire des castings
et de proposer le thé
à certaines demoiselles.
Il est connu pour être,
je cite son surnom
dans le milieu cinématographique,
le bouc de Babelsberg.
Babelsberg,
c'est le Hollywood allemand,
ce sont les studios
près de Potsdam,
le bouc de Babelsberg.
En 1936,
Goebbels noue une idylle amoureuse
avec une starlette de 22 ans,
Lída Baarová.
"Allo... quoi ?
Nous partons en voyage,
non ?
Aujourd'hui ?"
C'est un faux pas
qui va avoir des répercussions
sur la carrière de Goebbels.
Pour mettre un terme
à cette liaison scandaleuse,
son épouse Magda,
désespérée, menace de divorcer.
Elle se confie
à l'ami le plus proche du couple,
Adolf Hitler.
- Hitler n'a pas de famille,
la famille allemande est celle
de Joseph et Magda Goebbels.
Quand cette famille
commence à échouer,
Hitler n'est pas content du tout,
lui impose de rompre
cette liaison-là
et de cesser
d'humilier Magda Goebbels
qu'Hitler aime comme étant une femme
allemande remarquable, une mère.
Hitler est tellement furieux
pour cette image,
mais aussi pour Magda Goebbels,
pour laquelle il a beaucoup d'affection,
qu'il se détourne de Goebbels
qui en souffre.
Dans le réseau
des collaborateurs d'Hitler,
un nouveau venu
va profiter de cette disgrâce
et réussir
une ascension exceptionnelle.
Albert Speer part pourtant de loin,
parmi les hommes
qui rejoignent le nazisme sur le tard.
Sur ces images de 1935,
on perçoit déjà leur complicité.
Hitler dessine, à côté de lui,
dans son costume impeccable
se tient Albert Speer, 27 ans,
un jeune architecte
qui n'a encore rien construit.
Dans sa jeunesse,
Hitler a lui-même dessiné
ces croquis de bâtiments pharaoniques,
tout en rêvant de les voir sortir de terre
le jour où il arriverait au pouvoir.
Hitler et Speer se connaissent
seulement depuis un an,
mais ils partagent une passion commune
pour l'architecture.
- Hitler a vu à travers Speer,
pratiquement la vie dont il rêvait.
Il a toujours dit qu'il voulait devenir
lui-même architecte,
et Speer s'est adapté
aux exigences d'Hitler.
Leurs projets étaient toujours
gigantesques, mégalomanes.
Hitler a remarqué Speer
ce 1er mai 1933 sur l'aéroport de Berlin,
lors de la fête du travail
qui réunit plus d'un million de personnes,
une marée humaine.
Hitler est fasciné par les festivités
qui se terminent
par un feu d'artifice grandiose,
où son visage crépite
au-dessus de l'assemblée.
L'organisation est signée
par Albert Speer,
ce grand bourgeois
qui vient d'adhérer au parti nazi
et à qui Goebbels
a passé ses premières commandes.
- C'est Goebbels
qui a présenté Speer à Hitler,
mais naturellement,
avec le temps est née une rivalité.
Goebbels a toujours trouvé très important
de faire partie de l'entourage d'Hitler
et bien sûr, dans ce cas-là,
Speer devenait un rival.
Très vite,
Speer occupe une place
privilégiée auprès d'Hitler.
Contrairement à Goebbels,
il est l'invité permanent
de son repaire dans la montagne.
Tous les deux apprécient
le même style pompeux
qui vient de l'antiquité.
Tout d'abord, Speer est l'architecte
de l'immense champ de parade de Nuremberg,
copié sur un temple dédié à Zeus.
Pour les congrès du parti,
cette esplanade peut accueillir
plus de 340 000 personnes.
Speer construit ensuite
au pied de la Tour Eiffel,
le pavillon allemand installé
pour l'exposition de Paris en 1937.
Cette même année,
Hitler va lui passer
la commande du siècle,
Germania,
la future capitale de son empire.
Ce chantier démesuré
doit durer jusqu'en 1950,
il s'agit
de reconstruire Berlin.
Le long d'une avenue de cinq kilomètres
appelée Avenue de la Victoire,
les bâtiments de Germania
seront les plus grands jamais conçus.
Tout au bout,
cette coupole réservée
à la grande halle du peuple,
sera 16 fois plus grande
que celle de Saint-Pierre de Rome,
ce qui en ferait aujourd'hui encore,
le plus vaste bâtiment au monde.
Pour les habitants de Berlin,
cela sera un tremblement de terre.
- Ce sont 50 000 appartements
qui devaient être rasés,
près de 200 000 Berlinois
auraient eu besoin d'être relogés,
alors qu'il y avait déjà
un grand manque de logements.
Pour tester
la rapidité de son architecte,
Hitler va lui lancer un défi,
Speer doit construire
le premier bâtiment de Germania
en seulement une année.
Huit mille ouvriers
venus de toute l'Allemagne
travaillent en même temps,
jour et nuit.
Ils bâtissent
la future chancellerie du Reich.
Pour plaire à Hitler,
Albert Speer livre le bâtiment
deux jours avant la date fixée.
Hitler prend possession
de son bâtiment
censé éblouir
les ambassadeurs du monde entier.
Sa chancellerie
est d'un luxe tapageur,
avec un hall de marbre,
un immense cabinet de travail
pour Hitler,
et des galeries
deux fois plus grandes
que celles
du château de Versailles.
Albert Speer a rattrapé
tous ses concurrents
dans l'estime d'Hitler.
- La proximité du pouvoir l'a fasciné.
Il faut imaginer que Speer
n'avait même pas 30 ans,
et il était déjà devenu un des conseillers
les plus influents d'Hitler.
Pendant ce temps-là,
à Munich,
un des complices historiques d'Hitler,
Himmler,
n'a pas reçu de ministère.
Il est juste nommé
chef de la police de Bavière.
Prêt à tout, il va mener
une épuration sanglante au sein du parti
connu sous le nom
de Nuit des Longs Couteaux.
- C'est un des nombreux
pas qu'il a accompli vers le pouvoir.
Hitler redoute
la puissance d'un autre chef,
Ernst Röhm.
Très populaire, il dirige les SA,
une puissante milice nazie
reconnaissable à ses chemises brunes.
Alors qu'il est sous ses ordres,
Himmler supervise
l'assassinat de Röhm
et de tout son état-major.
- Même au prix du sang,
si un camarade se trouve sur sa route,
il ne voit pas d'inconvénient
à ce qu'il soit éliminé,
même si cela représente
un grand danger.
Himmler sort grand vainqueur
de ce bain de sang.
Son organisation, la SS,
l'Ordre noir, n'a désormais plus de rival,
Himmler va pouvoir
en faire bien plus qu'une simple milice.
- Pour lui,
la SS est un véritable projet politique
dont il a réussi
à convaincre Hitler aussi.
Himmler voue un culte
à la race germanique.
Il se réfère
à un roi mort au moyen-âge,
il va se recueillir sur sa tombe,
et il présente Hitler
comme son successeur à travers l'histoire.
"Le roi Henri I a transmis il y a
mille ans à notre Führer Adolf Hitler,
des valeurs humaines
et le rôle de guide pour l'Allemagne,
pour la Germanie."
Himmler veut construire
une société nouvelle,
profondément raciste
où les Germains de pure race
seront les seuls maîtres
pour les siècles à venir.
Pour que le sang de la race supérieure
se reproduise à grande échelle,
Himmler fonde
des maternités spéciales
où les SS peuvent abandonner
les nouveau-nés
qui seront élevés par le régime.
- Ça fonctionne un peu comme
la reproduction contrôlée des chevaux.
Vous amenez vos pouliches
dans les étables,
il y a des étalons qui sont là,
ils engrossent vos pouliches, etc.
Pour fonder la race supérieure,
les Nazis veulent aussi éliminer
ce qu'ils appellent des vies sans valeur.
Dès 1935,
dans tous les cinémas,
ces terribles films de propagande
sont diffusés.
Ils montrent les handicapés
sous un jour effrayant.
Le film insiste surtout
sur les dépenses pour la société
que représentent ces malades
qui passent toute leur vie en hôpital.
Cette femme atteinte
d'une maladie héréditaire
coûterait 153 000 marks
par an à la communauté.
Ces trois frères et sœurs,
62 300 marks,
ces épileptiques,
plus de 20 000 marks.
Pour manipuler l'opinion,
une estimation de plus
de 1,2 milliard de marks
correspondrait aux coûts financiers
de toutes les maladies héréditaires.
Les Nazis veulent justifier
les crimes qu'ils préparent.
- Il faut d'abord séparer
et empêcher ces vies sans valeur
de nuire au peuple,
et à partir de 1939,
ont commencé à se mettre en place
de véritables programmes de mise à mort,
notamment des handicapés
physiques et mentaux.
Himmler ne cesse
de tout vouloir remodeler,
il veut aussi
que ses SS aient leurs propres croyances.
"Je jure ici,
à Adolf Hitler,
fidélité et bravoure."
Des cérémonies étranges
ont lieu dans les chapelles
du château de Wewelsburg,
le centre de formation des SS,
avec ce soleil noir comme symbole occulte.
Des baptêmes se déroulent
selon les rites SS.
Himmler, lui-même,
célèbre des mariages.
Les Nazis veulent balayer toutes
les croyances religieuses qui existent.
- Si les Nazis avaient gagné,
il y aurait eu un nouveau calendrier,
de nouvelles fêtes
de nouvelles liturgies,
un nouveau baptême,
une nouvelle fête
qui n'auarait pas été celle de Noël.
C'est aussi ça l'utopie nazie,
c'est une révolution si importante
et si globale,
qu'elle devait tout changer,
tout, y compris la croyance
et y compris Dieu.
Dans le secret,
au milieu des années 30,
Hitler va prendre
une décision stratégique
qu'il partage d'abord
avec son bras droit.
- Hitler, lui-même,
fixe un programme qui, en gros,
dit qu'il fallait que l'Allemagne
soit prête pour entrer en guerre
dans quatre ans,
et pour réaliser ce programme,
il crée une nouvelle administration
avec un chef du plan de quatre ans,
c'est Hermann Goering.
Du jour au lendemain, en 1936,
Hermann Goering est propulsé
à la tête de l'industrie allemande.
Son enveloppe financière
est illimitée,
ses commandes
mobilisent plus de 228 usines,
une puissance de feu
unique au monde à l'époque.
Les Allemands, privés d'armées
depuis la défaite
de la Première Guerre mondiale,
préparent leur revanche.
"Mes chers compatriotes,
mes chers frères d'armes,
quel est le but
de ce plan de 4 ans ?
Je pourrais le résumer
en une phrase essentielle :
la sauvegarde
de l'honneur allemand
et la sauvegarde
de la vie allemande."
Ces nouvelles fonctions
permettent aussi à Goering de s'enrichir.
Pour ses anniversaires,
par exemple,
les industriels le couvrent de cadeaux.
Il reçoit
des pièces de collection,
mais il a une prédilection
pour les toiles de maîtres
et les pierres précieuses.
Le système corrompu
qu'il met en place est bien organisé.
- Son bureau a envoyé
des petites listes,
comme des listes de mariage,
aux différents représentants
des entreprises
en leur disant que le maréchal aimerait
bien avoir telle ou telle œuvre d'art,
ou tel ou tel objet
en tant que cadeau.
Hermann Goering joue
les empereurs romains,
il aime les excentricités
comme poser avec un lionceau.
"Oui, mon César.
Est-ce que tu me rends visite ?
Viens !
Est-ce que tu es rassasié César ?
Allez joli, saute !
C'est bien !"
Hitler désigne Goering
comme son successeur.
Depuis le décès de Carin,
sa première femme morte d'un cancer,
il manque aux Allemands
une première dame,
alors son second mariage à Berlin
est digne d'une tête couronnée.
Trente mille soldats
jalonnent le parcours.
Hitler, son témoin,
a favorisé ces noces grandioses
pour cacher sa propre vie privée.
Emma et Hermann Goering
incarnent maintenant
le couple officiel du régime.
Ils représentent
de plus en plus le pouvoir nazi
dans les grandes occasions,
comme ici,
lors d'une réception
en l'honneur de Mussolini.
Pour recevoir,
Goering a fait aménager
son immense domaine aux portes de Berlin.
Des centaines d'œuvres d'art
recouvrent les murs de ce palais.
- Il y avait aussi beaucoup
de trophées de chasse.
Dieter Wellershoff
côtoie Goering plusieurs fois.
Très jeune, il a été enrôlé
dans les jeunesses hitlériennes
et à l'âge de 17 ans,
il a été pendant quelques mois soldat
dans la propriété de Goering.
- Quand il nous passait en revue,
Goering disait toujours
qu'une fois qu'il était passé devant nous,
nous pouvions nous relâcher.
On n'était alors plus obligé
de se tenir droit.
Il fallait choisir un chemin
sans flaques d'eau et sans boue
pour que cet homme gros et lourd
puisse marcher.
Il était grotesque.
S'il occupe
le premier plan de la scène,
Goering a bien du mal
à contenir Hitler.
Le Führer est maintenant prêt
à déclencher la guerre.
Hitler assiste régulièrement
à des répétitions de combats.
Malgré ces immenses exercices
en grandeur nature,
Goering peine
à freiner son impatience,
car il sait que le plan
pour préparer l'Allemagne
à la guerre a pris du retard.
- Il explique,
à ce moment-là, à Hitler,
que l'Allemagne
n'était pas encore prête.
Pourtant,
avec une année d'avance
sur le plan qu'il a lui-même fixé,
Hitler ordonne
de passer à l'attaque.
- Il vit dans un film,
il vit dans une pièce de théâtre,
il est, lui-même acteur,
et sa guerre à lui,
ce sont des cartes déployées
sur une gigantesque table,
des drapeaux qui avancent
et des pions qu'il déplace.
Pour Hitler et ses complices,
l'entrée dans la guerre en 1939
est d'une facilité déconcertante.
L'Armée allemande semble invincible.
Au bout d'une seule année
de combat,
la Pologne,
le Danemark,
la Norvège,
la Belgique,
la Hollande
et la France sont envahis.
La moitié de l'Europe s'effondre
et le partage de l'Empire
entre les complices d'Hitler
va être sanglant.
- De Goebbels dépend
telle administration,
de Goering telle autre,
d'Himmler telle autre,
et on se rend compte
que dans la politique de conquête,
de colonisation,
de prédation, de spoliation,
il y a chevauchement
des compétences,
et tout cela crée
des frictions, des tensions.
Le grand pillage commence,
Goering fait de Paris
son terrain de chasse.
Il débarque
dans une limousine décapotable,
sillonne les rues,
et descend place Vendôme
dans un palace,
Le Ritz.
Goering est venu se servir
dans les musées français,
Matisse, Monet,
Cézanne,
ils s'emparent
de centaines de tableaux
pour compléter
sa gigantesque collection.
La même année,
Hitler débarque aussi à Paris,
Albert Speer, son architecte,
est à ses côtés.
Il lui promet de copier
les plus beaux monuments
de la capitale française
pour leur futur Germania.
- Hitler a été
très impressionné par Paris,
les Champs-Élysées,
l'Arc de Triomphe,
il voulait bien évidemment
reproduire tout cela à Berlin,
mais dans des dimensions
bien plus grandes.
De retour à Berlin,
le maréchal Goering triomphe
aux premières loges.
Il dirige les opérations militaires,
et pourtant,
il cache la réalité à Hitler.
- C'est bien sûr,
du point de vue du public,
un succès fulgurant.
Du point de vue du chef de l'économie,
c'est une catastrophe,
parce qu'après
les quelques semaines de combat,
l'Allemagne ne dispose plus
de bombes,
plus de munitions
et très peu d'avions.
Par peur de déplaire à Hitler,
Goering ne dira rien.
Vantard,
il lui promet au contraire
d'écraser l'Angleterre
en seulement trois semaines.
Himmler s'est taillé
un empire dans l'Est de l'Europe
où il supervise
une politique ignoble d'extermination,
avec une froideur totale.
Quand Hitler
lui rend visite en Pologne,
ses soldats SS mènent
déjà leur grande guerre raciste.
Himmler passe son temps
à motiver ses troupes
pour justifier
les assassinats systématiques.
- Ce qu'il dit toujours à ses SS,
c'est que c'est difficile à supporter,
comme une épreuve,
une tâche pénible
qu'ils doivent effectuer,
mais il dit qu'ils étaient moralement
suffisamment forts.
- Il pense ça
sur le mode sacrificiel,
il disait
qu'il sacrifiait son psychisme
pour que leurs enfants
puissent vivre, etc.
Il y a tout un discours derrière ça.
À partir de 1939, en Pologne,
puis à partir de 1941, en URSS,
les Nazis expérimentent
des politiques d'assassinats
et de déportations de masse.
Sous les ordres d'Himmler,
ils construisent leur espace vital,
un empire colonial peuplé d'esclaves
et débarrassé de ses Juifs.
- Ce projet implique la mort de dizaines
de millions de personnes par la faim,
on est dans un imaginaire
du laisser-mourir.
Parallèlement, en Ukraine,
mais aussi dans les pays baltes,
opèrent de petits groupes mobiles
de tueurs SS appelés Einsatzgruppen.
Ces atrocités se succèdent
à un rythme effréné.
Plus d'un million de personnes
seront exterminées par les fusillades.
En août 1941,
Himmler se rend
à Minsk, en Biélorussie,
pour évaluer en personne
cette stratégie de mise à mort.
Il inspecte d'abord
les prisonniers soviétiques
et assiste personnellement
à ces exécutions par balles.
- Himmler,
lors d'une visite à Minsk,
à l'été 1941,
va être le témoin
de l'exécution de 100 Juifs.
100 Juifs sont exécutés
à titre d'exemple
pour montrer à Himmler
comment ça se passe.
Himmler va défaillir
devant le spectacle,
et Himmler est l'un des pires antisémites
du Troisième Reich,
un antisémite convaincu, enragé.
Ce n'est pas par pitié
pour les victimes juives,
c'est juste que le spectacle,
pour le tueur,
ça engendre un traumatisme.
Aussi insupportable
que cela puisse paraître,
Himmler,
en tant que grand chef des SS,
ne s'inquiète que des traumatismes
psychologiques pour ses hommes.
- Vous avez des hommes
qui ne sont pas des tueurs-nés,
donc il y a différents pas
à leur faire accepter
avant qu'ils se mettent à tuer.
- À la suite de la tuerie à Minsk,
Himmler va demander
à ses hommes à Berlin
de trouver la méthode
pour épargner les tueurs.
En 1941,
différentes méthodes
d'assassinats de masse cohabitent,
mais à la fin de l'année,
un ordre venu d'Hitler en personne
va unifier les procédures.
Il exige l'extermination
de tous les Juifs d'Europe.
Trois ans plus tôt,
Hitler avait prévenu,
si la guerre devenait mondiale,
il mettrait sa menace à exécution.
"Aujourd'hui encore
je serai un prophète.
Si la finance juive internationale,
en Europe et hors d'Europe,
devait parvenir à précipiter les peuples
dans une guerre mondiale,
alors le résultat ne serait pas
la bolchévisation du monde,
donc la victoire de la juiverie,
au contraire, ce sera
l'anéantissement de la race juive !"
C'est l'entrée en guerre
des États-Unis en décembre 1941
qui motive finalement sa décision.
- La Solution Finale
est décidée par Hitler.
- À ce moment-là,
les exécutions massives ont lieu.
- Dans cette année-là,
il y a pratiquement 4 millions de Juifs
qui ont été exterminés.
Pour Himmler,
il n'est pas envisageable
d'assassiner des millions de personnes
par les fusillades de masse.
- C'est pour cette raison
que le gazage va être vu
comme un recours efficient
pour protéger les tueurs.
Le gazage n'est pas introduit
pour tuer plus de gens,
en revanche, les chambres à gaz
ont un mérite majeur,
c'est d'épargner les tueurs.
Il n'y a plus de contact
avec les victimes,
on ne voit plus les gens mourir,
on ramasse les corps à la fin.
Himmler décide alors
de concentrer sur un lieu unique
toutes ces nouvelles politiques
d'extermination.
Un lieu gigantesque
qui va devenir le plus grand
des camps de concentration
et des centres de mise à mort,
un lieu vers lequel vont être déportés
1,3 million de personnes.
- Un, il faut que ce soit un lieu
central dans l'empire nazi,
deux, il faut que ce soit bien relié
à toutes les parties de l'Europe
et trois, qu'il soit doté
d'une filière de mise à mort
qui soit extrêmement
rapide et efficace.
Le véritable nœud ferroviaire
et central de l'empire nazi
qui va être choisi,
c'est Auschwitz.
Himmler confie Auschwitz
à un fonctionnaire de terrain,
un des pires spécialistes des camps,
il s'appelle Rudolf Hoess,
Il devient, à l'âge de 40 ans,
directeur de l'un des plus vastes projets
du Troisième Reich.
Ces images d'Auschwitz
que nous connaissons,
sont celles de la libération du camp
en 1945 par les soldats soviétiques.
Pour diriger ce vaste complexe,
le plus grand camp de l'empire nazi,
Heinrich Himmler avait le choix
entre plusieurs responsables,
mais il a choisi Rudolf Hoess,
un homme
qui a un passé de meurtrier.
- En 1923,
Hoess assassine un homme,
un communiste,
qui a été détenu en prison
pendant cinq ans.
À sa sortie de prison,
Himmler l'a pris sous son aile
et a fini par lui trouver
une nouvelle profession.
- Au début des années 30,
Himmler est allé
voir mon grand-père
et lui a suggéré d'intégrer la SS.
Rainer Hoess est le petit-fils
du commandant d'Auschwitz,
Hans, son père,
est le plus jeune fils de Rudolf Hoess.
- Il a d'abord eu un poste
au camp de Dachau,
il est resté là-bas quatre ans,
puis il est devenu
chef de la détention,
puis directeur adjoint
du camp de Sachsenhausen,
et en 1940, grâce à Himmler,
il a été nommé directement
commandant d'Auschwitz.
Quand il arrive
dans la localité d'Auschwitz
en 1940 pour installer un camp,
Hoess ne découvre
qu'une petite ville de 15 000 habitants
ainsi qu'une ancienne caserne
de l'Armée polonaise,
où il établit le premier
lieu de détention, Auschwitz I.
Il repère aussi une villa
qui jouxte le camp.
Hoess s'empare de cette maison
dont les propriétaires polonais
sont expropriés.
Au deuxième étage,
depuis la fenêtre de son bureau,
cette vue plongeante
sur le crématorium ne le gêne pas.
Le commandant
s'installe dans la villa
avec sa femme Edwige
et leurs cinq enfants.
La famille ne pense
qu'à son ascension sociale.
Ces photos de l'album familial
en attestent,
leur nouveau cadre de vie
assure un confort inespéré.
À 70 mètres
des fours crématoires,
le jardin entouré d'un grand mur
devient le terrain
de jeu favori des enfants.
- C'était si grand
qu'il pouvait faire du vélo à l'intérieur.
Aujourd'hui,
on dirait qu'à cette époque,
mes grands-parents sont passés
de l'état d'anonyme à celui de VIP.
Grâce au camp de concentration,
les Hoess mènent une vie confortable
avec une main-d'œuvre
réduite en esclavage.
- Il a un détenu
qui sert de jardinier,
des détenus
qui servent de serviteurs
à l'intérieur de la maison,
qui s'occupaient éventuellement
des enfants au besoin.
Il y a tout pour bénéficier,
en tout cas,
d'un embourgeoisement à Auschwitz.
- Mon grand-père écrit dans ses mémoires
que c'était le paradis.
Comme tous les responsables SS,
Hoess est constamment
motivé par Himmler
dont les arguments
n'ont été enregistrés qu'une seule fois,
pour un usage interne.
"La plupart d'entre vous savent
ce que c'est que 100 cadavres,
500 ou 1 000 cadavres.
Avoir tenu
dans ces circonstances-là,
et être restés dignes,
à part quelques cas
de défaillance humaine,
cela nous a endurcis !
C'est une page de gloire de notre histoire
qui n'a jamais été écrite,
et ne le sera plus jamais !
Dès 1941,
Himmler ordonne à Hoess qu'Auschwitz
passe à l'échelle industrielle
pour recevoir
de plus en plus de convois.
Les bâtiments en briques rouges
de l'ancienne caserne ne suffisent plus.
À trois kilomètres
de ce premier site,
débute alors
la construction de Birkenau,
un gigantesque
camp de concentration,
mais aussi un centre
de mise à mort où, dès leur arrivée,
les déportés sont envoyés
directement dans les chambres à gaz.
Hoess utilise aussi les prisonniers
pour alimenter en main-d'œuvre
tout un complexe industriel.
Une grande usine chimique s'installe,
à la pointe
de la technologie de l'époque,
elle fabrique notamment,
du caoutchouc pour les pneus.
- L'ensemble Auschwitz,
c'est-à-dire les camps,
la ville, les usines,
c'est un chantier
permanent et incessant,
de 1940 à quasiment 1945,
à la fin de la guerre.
Auschwitz ne cesse de se diversifier.
Après cette immense usine,
Hoess développe
un grand projet agricole avec Himmler.
- Il partage ça avec
Heinrich Himmler, qui a fait,
à partir de 1918,
des études d'agronomie,
donc ils ont
une passion commune.
Hoess supervise
l'implantation de ces serres
pour faire des recherches
sur de nouvelles plantes.
À partir de 1943,
le camp de Birkenau devient immense.
Le nouveau pôle agricole
s'établit dans un petit hameau,
Rajsko.
Pendant la guerre,
Auschwitz devient
une ville modèle pour les Nazis,
la population
est multipliée par quatre.
Au sein du camp,
aux côtés de Rudolf Hoess,
un autre grand criminel nazi
profite aussi des convois
qui arrivent à Auschwitz.
Fils de riches industriels,
le docteur Joseph Mengele
mène des expériences médicales.
- Mengele mène
des recherches officielles
dans un cadre officiel,
le camp de concentration.
Il menait, d'une manière
comme à la boucherie.
Dans les services médicaux des camps
et les académies de médecine,
les docteurs nazis
procèdent à d'atroces mutilations,
notamment sur les corps
des déportés juifs et tsiganes.
- Des médecins à qui on a donné
tout pouvoir sur des individus
qui ne sont plus relégués
au rang d'êtres humains,
mais au rang de matériau humain
sur lequel on va procéder
à toutes les recherches
qu'on estime nécessaires
pour faire progresser
la médecine dans tel ou tel rayon.
Les expériences du docteur Mengele
nécessitent, elles, des enfants.
Dans cette colonne de petits rescapés,
filmés ici en 1945,
au premier rang,
deux petites sœurs jumelles
se donnent la main.
Juives de Hongrie,
elles s'appellent Miriam et Eva,
11 ans à l'époque.
- Nous étions de petits enfants,
des petites filles âgés de deux à 16 ans,
affamées,
nous n'avions aucun droit,
mais la féroce détermination
de vivre un jour de plus.
Lorsqu'elles débarquent
sur le quai d'Auschwitz-Birkenau en 1944
avec les cinq membres de sa famille,
Eva doit,
dès la descente du train,
subir la sélection
opérée par les SS
qui reçoivent les convois
et travaillent pour Mengele.
- Un Nazi courait
et criait en allemand,
"jumeaux, jumeaux."
Il a remarqué que nous étions
habillées pareilles, Miriam et moi.
Il demanda à ma mère
si nous étions jumelles,
et ma mère demanda
si c'était bon pour nous.
Le Nazi dit oui.
Aussitôt, un autre Nazi poussa
ma mère dans une direction
et nous dans l'autre.
Elle pleurait et nous pleurions.
Dépouillés de leurs affaires,
quatre membres de sa famille
sont envoyés à la chambre à gaz.
Si Eva et sa sœur survivent,
c'est pour être utilisées
par les expériences du docteur Mengele.
Chaque jour,
elles sont conduites
au service médical du camp qu'il dirige.
- Il me prenait un peu de sang
dans le bras gauche
et il me faisait au minimum
cinq injections par jour
dans le bras droit.
Ce qu'il y avait dans ces injections,
on ne le savait pas à l'époque,
et malheureusement, je ne le sais
toujours pas aujourd'hui.
Ces injections rendent
Eva gravement malade
et occasionnent une très forte fièvre.
- Le lendemain,
le docteur Mengele est venu
avec quatre autres médecins.
Il ne m'a pas examiné,
il a juste regardé
ma courbe de température
et il a déclaré
en riant sur un ton sarcastique
que c'était dommage,
j'étais si jeune
et que je n'avais plus
que deux semaines à vivre.
Ces expériences
de Mengele sur les jumeaux,
des actes de torture,
jouent un rôle stratégique pour les Nazis.
- Au cœur même
de l'idéologie nazie,
il y a cette idée
que le sang aryen est rare
et tout doit être fait
pour promouvoir la reproduction
et permette la croissance
de la population aryenne,
donc il faut essayer
de trouver une méthode
qui permette des naissances
de jumeaux ou de triplés.
- Ils essayaient d'accoupler
entre eux les jumeaux
en âge de se reproduire
pour voir si la fille tombait enceinte,
et si elle allait
avoir des jumeaux à son tour.
Ils voulaient accroître
la race aryenne.
Eva et sa sœur survivent,
atteintes à jamais
de graves déficiences physiques.
1,1 million de personnes
périssent à Auschwitz.
À partir de la fin de 1941,
Hitler et ses complices
connaissent leur premier revers.
Goering considère
que mener la guerre en même temps,
à l'Ouest et à l'Est
de l'Europe est une folie,
mais encore une fois,
il n'affronte pas Hitler.
- Goering, au début,
était très sceptique en ce qui concerne
une offensive vers l'Est,
et là, il se rend très vite compte
qu'apparemment,
Hitler a pris sa décision.
Ça, c'est la règle pour Goering,
si Hitler a pris une décision,
c'est à lui d'obéir aux ordres.
C'est Goering qui avait raison.
Face à l'URSS,
l'armée allemande n'avait pas pris
la mesure de l'hiver glacial,
les troupes s'épuisent.
Devant Stalingrad,
les pertes sont énormes.
À cette époque,
le jeune Dieter est passé
des Jeunesses hitlériennes au front russe,
où il combat
dans la division Hermann Goering.
Le jeune soldat n'a que 17 ans.
- Ce que j'ai appris
des adultes qui étaient là,
c'est que Goering
avait un avis différent d'Hitler,
il ne voulait pas la guerre.
Lors d'une conversation avec Hitler,
Goering a dit qu'il ne voulait
pas jouer à un jeu de hasard
et Hitler a répondu
qu'il n'avait toujours joué
qu'aux jeux de hasard.
Engagés dans de multiples combats,
les Allemands manquent
de l'armement nécessaire.
Mais Hitler ne veut rien entendre.
Il cherche
dans sa garde rapprochée
un complice capable
de lui promettre un miracle.
Goering, qui a déjà dirigé
l'industrie de l'armement,
se porte candidat.
Hitler lui préfère
un collaborateur plus motivé,
il choisit son architecte,
Albert Speer.
- Hitler lui a dit qu'il devait
devenir ministre de l'Armement.
Speer a dit qu'il n'avait
aucune formation dans ce domaine,
Hitler a insisté
en disant qu'il allait le faire,
donc il a accepté cette mission.
Sans Speer, la guerre
n'aurait pas duré aussi longtemps.
"Le ministre du Reich pour l'armement
et la production de guerre,
Albert Speer,
en visite dans
une entreprise d'armement,
a remercié les ouvriers
pour les investissements,
dans l'incroyable
augmentation de la production."
Hitler lui a demandé
de doubler les cadences de production,
mais dès le début pour Speer,
le problème semble compliqué.
Les hommes
sont envoyés au front,
les femmes les ont remplacés
dans les usines d'armement.
La propagande
les a même encouragées
à abandonner
leurs emplois précédents.
"Cette travailleuse était encore il y a
peu couturière dans un salon de mode.
Celle-ci,
vendeuse dans une bijouterie."
vendeuse dans une parfumerie.
C'est encore insuffisant pour atteindre
les objectifs exorbitants
dictés par Hitler.
De surcroît,
Speer est chargé de superviser
la mise au point d'armes secrètes
qui doivent inverser
le cours de la guerre,
notamment les missiles V1 et V2
qui sont testés depuis plus de cinq ans.
Ces premiers
missiles balistiques de l'histoire
seraient capables
de frapper l'Angleterre.
Contre toute attente,
Speer réussit le miracle.
Alors que le pays subit
des bombardements au cours de l'année 1943
comme ici, à Hambourg,
il parvient à doubler
la production de l'armement.
Les canons et les tanks
sont assemblés à la chaîne
dans d'immenses usines,
où les ouvriers travaillent
plus de 70 heures par semaine.
Mais son miracle a aussi
une face cachée.
- En raison
des bombardements alliés,
les centres-villes étaient détruits
et certains sites industriels également.
C'est à ce moment-là
qu'est venue l'idée
d'installer
la production sous terre.
Au centre de l'Allemagne,
dans une région de forêt
à 150 kilomètres d'Hanovre,
un projet tentaculaire
va être enfoui sous cette colline.
Les Nazis imaginent un réseau
de galeries de plus de 12 kilomètres
qui traversent de part en part
toute la montagne de Mittelbau-Dora.
On y pénètre par cette vaste entrée
haute de sept mètres.
L'ancienne mine se présente comme
une interminable succession de tunnels.
Ce labyrinthe comprend 45 travées,
c'est la plus grande
usine souterraine du monde
où les ouvriers assemblent
les fameux missiles V2.
Mais c'est aussi le cœur
du système organisé par Albert Speer.
Des milliers de déportés
venus des camps de concentration
y sont enfermés nuit et jour
pour travailler comme des esclaves.
Sur les 60 000 prisonniers du tunnel,
20 000 y laisseront la vie,
dont plus de 2 000 Français.
Albert Speer dira toujours ne rien savoir
de ces conditions de vie barbare
qui rendent possible son miracle.
Hitler le considère
comme un génie de l'organisation,
il le décore.
L'ambition de Speer
irrite ses rivaux.
- Speer a réussi à instrumentaliser
le système des camps
pour l'industrie de l'armement.
On sait qu'en dehors d'Hitler,
Himmler craignait
particulièrement un rival,
et il s'agissait de Speer,
parce qu'il arrivait toujours
à s'imposer auprès d'Hitler.
Le miracle de Speer ne suffit pas,
les nouvelles du front russe
sont de plus en plus catastrophiques
pour les Allemands.
200 000 soldats
sont faits prisonniers.
Goering porte maintenant
physiquement le poids de la défaite.
Sa consommation de drogue
augmente en flèche,
bouffie, les yeux vitreux,
il pèse plus de 120 kilos.
- Il se sent inutile,
c'est une crise personnelle
et cette crise,
il essaye de se calmer
en prenant des médicaments
à base de morphine
ou d'autres choses.
C'est à ce moment-là
qu'on se moque de plus en plus de lui,
non seulement le public allemand,
mais c'est aussi Hitler
qui devient de plus en plus critique.
Pourtant, sur le front de l'Est,
lorsque le maréchal Goering inspecte
la Panzerdivision baptisée de son nom,
tous les soldats doivent encore
faire semblant de croire à la victoire.
Parmi les combattants de cette unité,
se trouve le jeune Dieter.
- On savait entre nous
que la guerre était perdue,
mais on pouvait juste le penser,
on ne pouvait pas le dire ouvertement.
Si quelqu'un disait
que la guerre était perdue
et que tout était fini,
il aurait été fusillé.
Pour freiner cette démotivation,
Hitler a besoin d'un collaborateur
capable d'enrôler
les Allemands derrière lui.
C'est l'heure pour le plus fanatique
de ses complices
de revenir en pleine lumière.
Palais des sports de Berlin,
le 18 février 1943,
Goebbels orchestre
une opération de communication.
Il a réuni une foule
de nazis convaincus,
mais aussi des blessés
qui rentrent du front.
Il a soigneusement choisi
ses 14 000 spectateurs.
"Les Anglais prétendent
que le peuple allemand
s'oppose aux mesures de guerre totale
de notre gouvernement.
Le peuple ne voudrait pas
la guerre totale selon les Anglais,
mais la capitulation !
Je vous demande :
voulez-vous la guerre totale ?"
Il crée un climat d'hystérie
en Allemagne.
"Voulez-vous cette guerre
si totale et si radicale
que nous ne pouvons l'imaginer ?
Je vous demande :
êtes-vous déterminés
à suivre le Führer en enfer
afin d'obtenir la victoire,
en acceptant les épreuves
personnelles les plus dures ?"
Ce soir-là, Goebbels, en transe,
va accomplir ce qu'il considère
comme la performance
la plus réussie de sa carrière.
"La guerre totale !
Nous la voulons !"
L'Allemagne doit se sacrifier
jusqu'au dernier,
l'Allemagne
ne capitulera jamais.
- Goebbels
est suffisamment intelligent
pour se rendre compte
que la situation est difficile,
peut-être désespérée.
Si la victoire est possible,
ce sera grâce à l'énergie,
à la volonté,
au sens du sacrifice.
Si la défaite est inéluctable,
les Nazis disparaîtront
avec un tel vacarme,
un tel fracas,
une telle apocalypse,
que du moins,
ils s'immortaliseront par leur sacrifice.
Son éternel rival, Goering,
est enfin disgracié.
Il revient au premier plan.
Goebbels déploie alors
une énergie hors du commun,
il visite les sinistrés
des villes bombardées,
écoute les plaintes,
remet des médailles,
et court les soupes populaires.
- Il va revenir
pleinement au premier plan
comme une sorte
de vice-Hitler au fond,
de deuxième Hitler,
au bénéfice de la catastrophe.
Goebbels élargit aussi
l'âge de la mobilisation
pour tous les Allemands.
Les hommes sont désormais
enrôlés jusqu'à 60 ans
et l'âge des plus jeunes
est abaissé à seulement 16 ans.
"Dans la mesure
où les Alliés approchent,
j'ai décidé de m'engager."
Les nouvelles recrues partent au front
dans leurs habits de tous les jours
avec les armes
qu'ils ont sous la main.
Goebbels a donné
un nom à l'opération,
Tempête du Peuple.
Dans Berlin en ruines,
où les habitants sont réduits
pour manger à fouiller dans les ordures,
une nouvelle de plus
va ébranler le moral des Nazis.
En Normandie,
les Alliés viennent de débarquer.
De jour en jour,
l'effondrement du Reich se profile.
La petite Margit
vit cachée à Berlin.
Pour fuir les Nazis, son père,
Juif, s'est exilé en Chine,
et depuis sa cachette,
en juillet 1944,
la petite fille reprend espoir
en entendant une nouvelle à la radio.
- Mon Dieu !
Le 20 juillet 1944,
c'était l'attentat contre Hitler
et ce que j'ai entendu
en premier à la radio,
c'était la voix d'Hitler
qui disait que la providence l'avait sauvé
et elle l'avait sauvé.
Dans cette pièce entièrement dévastée
de son quartier général,
Hitler a survécu miraculeusement
à un attentat à la bombe.
Autour de lui,
on a compté quatre morts
et neuf blessés graves
auxquels il rend visite à l'hôpital.
L'attentat a été organisé
par des hauts gradés
qui voulaient négocier avec les Alliés
la capitulation de l'Allemagne.
Ce complot contre Hitler
déclenche des milliers d'arrestations,
de tortures et d'assassinats.
Speer,
Himmler,
Goering,
Goebbels, savent maintenant tous
ce qu'ils risquent s'ils le trahissent.
Mais ils vont faire
des choix très différents.
Ses complices sont tous censés
suivre leur Führer
jusque dans le sacrifice
de leur vie.
Ils sont maintenant piégés par Hitler
qui a perdu sa lucidité.
En mars 1945,
il marche au ralenti.
Sur ces images de propagande,
il s'assoit face à une carte
et face à des généraux tétanisés
qui n'osent pas évoquer la défaite.
- Il les domine, il les fait taire,
il les rabroue,
il leur hurle dessus.
Mais au printemps 1945,
il déplace des petits drapeaux
et des pions qui n'existent plus.
Ce 20 avril 1945,
le jour du 56ème anniversaire d'Hitler,
c'est la dernière fois
qu'ils sont filmés ensemble.
Goering et Himmler paradent,
apparemment tout sourire,
mais ce n'est plus qu'une illusion.
Quelques heures plus tard,
ils abandonnent
précipitamment Hitler.
- Goering apprend qu'Hitler décide
de ne pas quitter Berlin.
Goering s'en va pour le Sud
de l'Allemagne, il s'enfuit.
À ce moment-là,
rester à Berlin équivaut à mourir.
Les soldats soviétiques
écrasent la ville sous les bombes.
Dans un bunker
sous la chancellerie monumentale,
des trois principaux complices,
seul Goebbels reste terré avec Hitler.
- Si ça mène au suicide,
à la mort, à la défaite,
ce n'est pas grave
parce que le docteur Goebbels,
propagandiste en chef,
aura travaillé à la mise
en scène de cette mort,
de telle sorte que pour
des siècles et des siècles,
le mythe de cette mort,
de ce sacrifice,
de sa disparition, résonnera.
Alors que l'Empire s'effondre,
Joseph Goebbels, le fanatique,
adresse aux Allemands le 21 avril,
un dernier message radio.
"Le moment de la vérité approche.
Je reste à Berlin
accompagné de tout mon cabinet.
Ma femme et mes enfants aussi
sont ici et vont rester à Berlin."
Alors que la ville
est aux mains des Soviétiques,
le 30 avril 1945, à 15 h,
Hitler se suicide.
Selon ses dernières volontés,
il désigne Joseph Goebbels
comme son successeur officiel.
Mais Goebbels n'est chancelier
que quelques heures.
Quand les Soviétiques arrivent
dans les jardins de la Chancellerie,
ils découvrent les corps calcinés
de Joseph et de Magda Goebbels
avec les cadavres
de leurs six enfants
qu'ils ont empoisonnés
avant de se suicider.
- Avec Magda Goebbels,
son épouse,
ils sont d'accord
pour dire qu'il n'y a pas d'avenir,
il n'y a pas de monde possible
sans le nazisme,
donc ils assassinent leurs enfants,
ils éteignent la génération d'après.
C'est fini.
Partout en Allemagne,
les Alliés découvrent la même scène,
des milliers de Nazis anonymes
ne veulent pas se rendre
et se suicident en famille.
Contrairement à Goebbels,
Himmler et Goering eux,
sont prêts à négocier.
- Himmler et Goering restent
des politiques jusqu'au bout,
c'est à dire des gens
qui laissent toutes les options ouvertes,
qui calculent
et qui veulent survivre.
Hermann Goering
s'est réfugié dans sa résidence
à la frontière
de l'Allemagne et de l'Autriche.
Avant sa mort Hitler l'a limogé.
Le Führer l'avait désigné
comme son successeur
alors, le 23 avril 1945,
Goering lui avait envoyé
ce télégramme classé confidentiel
où il s'était proposé
de le remplacer.
"Si des négociations
s'avèrent nécessaires,
je serai en meilleure position
que vous à Berlin.
- Là, il demande à Hitler
si vous n'êtes plus capable
de prendre des décisions,
c'est maintenant à moi
de prendre vos fonctions.
Hitler a considéré ce télégramme
comme une grave trahison.
- C'est pour cela que Goering
est destitué de toutes ses fonctions.
Finalement, en mai 1945,
Goering
se rend aux Américains.
Sa femme et sa fille
sont placées sous bonne garde.
Goering est encore persuadé
qu'il va pouvoir négocier
une reddition avec les honneurs,
il est Maréchal,
le plus haut grade militaire,
mais on lui annonce
qu'il va être traité comme un criminel.
- Il comprend
d'une minute à l'autre
qu'il n'a aucune chance
de négocier quoi que ce soit,
parce que c'est une capitulation
sans conditions
que les Alliés ont demandées
depuis des années.
Hitler a aussi été trahi
par son fidèle Heinrich Himmler.
Le chef des SS est en fuite.
Depuis le mois de février 1945,
pour sauver sa tête,
Himmler est entré
secrètement en contact avec les Alliés
pour négocier la capitulation.
Il a même autorisé
ces bus blancs de la Croix-Rouge
à sauver plus de 13 000 prisonniers
qu'il a fait libérer des camps.
- Himmler a joué un double jeu
à la fin de la guerre,
quand il a mené des négociations
dans le dos d'Hitler avec les Alliés.
On remarque
sa déconnexion de la réalité,
il a vraiment cru que les Alliés
étaient prêts à l'accepter
en position de force.
Quand il comprend
qu'il n'est pas crédible,
Himmler se cache parmi
des soldats allemands faits prisonniers.
Il veut se noyer dans la masse,
déguisé sous une fausse identité.
Il est finalement reconnu
près d'Hambourg,
et au moment
où il est fouillé dans cette maison
par un médecin anglais,
Himmler croque
une capsule de cyanure,
le poison
qu'il gardait caché dans la bouche.
Il meurt immédiatement.
L'assassin du siècle
ne rendra jamais de compte.
- Il a voulu échapper
à ses responsabilités,
pas seulement en fuyant,
mais également en se suicidant
pour ne pas comparaître devant un juge.
Le même jour, à Flensburg,
dans le Nord de l'Allemagne,
les derniers responsables nazis
sont arrêtés.
Parmi eux
figure le protégé d'Hitler,
Albert Speer,
l'architecte et ministre de l'Armement.
À l'été 1945,
parmi les complices
de la garde rapprochée d'Hitler,
seuls Goering
et Speer sont encore en vie.
En bas de l'échelle,
Hoess a aussi survécu.
Ils vont répondre
de leurs crimes face aux juges,
ils pensent encore
s'en sortir vivants.
À Nuremberg,
ce 20 novembre 1945,
s'ouvre le procès du siècle.
Ces magistrats américains,
anglais, russes et français
doivent juger les 24 plus grands
criminels nazis encore en vie.
Tous risquent la peine de mort
et pour la première fois de l'histoire,
ils devront répondre
d'un nouveau crime,
le crime contre l'humanité.
L'accusé numéro un
est Hermann Goering,
aminci,
guéri de sa dépendance à la drogue,
il se sent
particulièrement combatif.
- Il était en pleine forme
à ce moment-là
et il a vraiment pris ce procès
comme un combat.
"Hermann
Wilhem
Goering."
Dès l'ouverture du procès,
Goering veut s'imposer.
Selon la procédure américaine,
les accusés doivent juste plaider
coupable ou non-coupable,
mais lui a préparé
une longue tirade.
"Avant de répondre au tribunal,
que je sois déclaré coupable
ou non coupable..."
Le Président
le rappelle à l'ordre.
"Je vous informe
que les accusés
ne sont pas autorisés
à faire de déclaration.
Vous devez simplement plaider
coupable ou non coupable.
Sur ces accusations,
je plaide non coupable !"
Après lui,
tous les accusés plaideront
non-coupable à leur tour.
"Non coupable !
Non coupable !
Non !"
Pendant le procès,
Goering occupe
le centre de l'attention,
il pense encore échapper
à la peine de mort par sa stratégie.
Il veut défendre le projet d'Hitler
pour l'Allemagne.
- Son idée, c'était vraiment,
à ce moment-là
de justifier son Führer.
Les juges ont prévu un électrochoc,
les criminels nazis doivent
être confrontés en plein tribunal
aux images insoutenables
filmées à la libération des camps.
Des images tournées
par les Américains et les Russes
pour témoigner à jamais
des atrocités organisées par les accusés.
Pendant la projection,
Goering détourne le regard,
il comprend
que sa défense s'écroule.
- Vu les images sur l'écran,
il avait très peu de chances
de réussir avec son idée
d'expliquer et de justifier
ce qui s'est passé pendant 12 ans.
Le témoignage glaçant
de Rudolf Hoess,
le commandant
du camp d'Auschwitz,
va encore accabler les accusés.
"Certes les détenus
étaient traités durement
mais avec une certaine méthode."
Jusqu'au bout,
ils défendent le régime nazi,
mais à Nuremberg,
un seul va renier ses convictions
et prétendre ne rien savoir
de l'Holocauste,
c'est pourtant
un des plus proches d'Hitler,
Albert Speer, l'architecte.
Hitler et l'effondrement de son régime
préparent une terrible période
de souffrance pour le peuple allemand.
Après ce procès,
je vais condamner Hitler
comme le responsable
de ce malheur.
- Il prétend qu'il aurait toujours pris
ses distances par rapport à Hitler,
il aurait même envisagé
de l'assassiner.
Bien sûr, c'était grotesque.
Le 1er octobre 1946,
après dix mois de procès à Nuremberg,
le verdict tombe.
"Accusé Hermann Wilhem Goering
le tribunal international
vous condamne
à mort par pendaison."
Douze accusés sont condamnés
à mort par pendaison.
La stratégie de Speer a payé,
il n'est condamné qu'à 20 ans de prison.
Goering ne veut pas être pendu
comme un simple délinquant,
mais mourir comme un soldat,
fusillé par un peloton d'exécution,
le tribunal lui refuse.
Alors, ultime provocation,
quelques heures
avant l'exécution de la sentence,
avec la complicité
d'un de ses gardiens américains,
Goering se procure une capsule
de poison et se suicide dans sa cellule,
persuadé encore
de laisser son empreinte dans l'histoire.
- Il a expliqué que maintenant,
on va me condamner,
mais dans une cinquantaine d'années,
vous allez voir,
on va avoir des petites statuettes
de Hermann Goering
dans tous les appartements
des Allemands.
Les responsables d'Auschwitz,
eux, sont livrés à la justice polonaise,
car les atrocités
se sont produites sur son sol.
Parmi eux,
Rudolf Hoess,
le directeur du camp.
Il est jugé à Varsovie
et condamné pour l'exemple,
à être pendu dans le camp,
sur le lieu de ses crimes.
- C'est effrayant de voir
la froideur de ses sentiments,
il n'exprime pas vraiment de regret
au sujet de ces assassinats,
pour lui,
il ne faisait qu'obéir aux ordres.
Les années passent,
dans la garde rapprochée d'Hitler,
un seul est resté vivant
et va devenir maître
dans l'art du mensonge.
Quand il sort de la prison de Spandau,
dans la banlieue de Berlin, en 1966,
Albert Speer n'a que 61 ans,
l'architecte et ministre d'Hitler
attire les médias du monde entier.
Après 20 ans de détention,
il est le seul
à pouvoir raconter de l'intérieur
le fonctionnement
du pouvoir sous Hitler.
- Lorsque Speer
est sorti de prison,
il avait déjà signé un contrat
très lucratif pour écrire ses mémoires.
Depuis deux ans,
Albert Speer est devenu
un auteur à succès,
ses mémoires écrites en prison
sont traduits en 14 langues
et sont vendues à plus
d'un million d'exemplaires.
C'est une star.
Speer est interviewé
sur tous plateaux TV du monde entier.
- Pourquoi est-ce qu'Hitler
a fait de vous un de ses amis ?
- Hitler n'a jamais eu d'amis
et je disais
au procès de Nuremberg,
que si Hitler
aurait eu des amis,
j'étais un de ses amis.
Peut-être que je réalise
son rêve de jeunesse.
Il continue à se présenter
comme un architecte
qui n'a pas eu connaissance
des pires crimes du régime.
- D'après ses affirmations,
il n'a rien su
de l'extermination des Juifs.
Dans les années 70,
Speer est peu à peu rattrapé
par des révélations
sur son implication dans l'Holocauste.
Notamment,
on sait,
grâce à cette photo,
qu'il a visitée en 1943,
le camp de Mauthausen
où plus de 200 000 personnes sont mortes,
et qu'il a entendu Himmler
évoquer l'extermination des Juifs.
- Si on avait su
tout ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui,
il aurait été condamné
à mort à Nuremberg.
C'était une personnalité
très dangereuse.
Sous un masque bourgeois,
il cachait sa vraie nature
de politicien glacial.
Albert Speer échappera
jusqu'au bout à la vérité.
Le dernier proche d'Hitler
meurt dans son lit
d'une crise cardiaque en 1981.
Joseph Mengele,
le médecin d'Auschwitz,
surnommé l'Ange de la mort,
meurt en 1979 au Brésil,
sans jamais avoir été
rattrapé par la justice.
Aucun de ces grands criminels
qui ont tant travaillé à la place d'Hitler
n'a aujourd'hui de tombe.
Leurs cendres ont été éparpillées
ou leurs dépouilles enterrées anonymement
pour éviter tout rassemblement
de nostalgiques.
Leurs traces
disparaissent peu à peu.
Au bout de ce chemin
perdu dans la forêt,
sans indication,
ces ruines laissées à l'abandon
sont celles
de la maison préférée d'Adolf Hitler,
où tous ses complices
se rencontraient.